c'est un graphique porteur d'optimisme
les pays qui entourent la france voient
leur population contaminée
quotidiennement par le cos vie 19
décroître avec un exemple édifiant celui
du royaume uni une baisse de 21% à 7
jours alors que les plus grandes
restrictions ont été levées
les britanniques semblent être plus
discipliné depuis la fin de l'euro de
foot le 11 juillet qui a vu l'angleterre
rallier la finale
[Applaudissements]
les écoles du royaume uni sont également
fermés pendant les vacances scolaires
sans oublier une campagne de vaccination
chiffres impressionnants
plus de 70% des adultes ont déjà reçu
deux doses
j'ai remarqué que de toute évidence les
chiffres s'améliorent depuis six jours
mais il est très très important que nous
nous permettrons pas de tirer des
conclusions prématurées à ce sujet les
jeunes de ce pays font un effort
incroyable pour se faire vacciner
les chiffres sont remarquables il ya
maintenant presque 70% des 18-30 ans qui
se sont fait vacciner
c'est tout simplement merveilleux et
charlebois de pauvres jeunes hommes et
jeunes femmes britanniques autorisé
d'ailleurs à reprendre les chemins des
discothèques
un sentiment de liberté qui ne concerne
le plus vraiment les néerlandais obligé
de se restreindre
de nouveau pour voir leur chiffre
baisser une pause décontamination
multipliée par sept en début de mois ont
contraint les autorités dès samedi 10
juillet à imposer notamment la fermeture
de toutes les boîtes de nuit et 7 et
restaurants à minuit chaque client devra
respecter une distance d'un mètre
cinquante incidents c'est direct la
courbe se casse quelques jours après
l'entrée en vigueur de ces nouvelles
mesures sanitaires vous constatez
maintenant que cet ensemble de
restrictions que nous avons dû
malheureusement resserré à l'époque
entraîne aujourd'hui heureusement une
forte diminution du nombre d'infections
entre vacciner massivement et ne pas
trop lâché du lest le gouvernement
portugais et essaie de trouver la
recette miracle pour stabiliser le
nombre d'infections comme on peut le
voir sur ce graphique mais sans pour
autant refouler les vacanciers depuis
début juillet le couvre feu avant 3h et
de rigueur et depuis plus de deux
semaines un passait ni théret demandé à
l'intérieur des restaurants et hôtels
moins d'interactions sociales objectif
également du gouvernement espagnol
le nombre de cas positifs se stabilise
ces dernières semaines
coïncidence ou pas les rassemblements de
plus de dix personnes sont interdits
tout comme manger et boire sur l'espace
public pour éviter l'accès aux parcs et
aux plages la catalogne très prisée a
décidé de prolonger son couvre-feu
jusqu'au 6 août de 1h à 6h du matin